it's been really exciting it's been so
surreal yeah I've had an amazing amazing
time I think coming on to such a
established family and established cast
was initially really intimidating and I
so nervous and my first day was with the
entire principal cast and I think I
could I did very nearly hyperventilated
in my trailer before I walked a set but
I got to set and everyone was so lovely
and really just chilled out and just
like nice to meet you and really just
kind of like you're one of us now and I
realize I had nothing to worry about and
it was just wonderful experience
sounds a little cliche sometimes but
family aren't screens so important it's
a family off screen tuna well yeah
because you have to have a certain level
of chemistry with people around you to
to show that on screen you know if you
don't get on I mean I think obviously
everyone's very very good actors and you
can you know but I think it's much more
real if it's coming from somewhere true
you know if you really feel like close
to people then that translates on
on-screen and them I think that's
definitely true for this for this group
of people and they just embraced me so
warmly you know I couldn't you know I
couldn't have asked for a lovely a
welcome for the Ramsay reveal is one of
the lot more fun moments in the movie
because no one is expecting to see you
when that hood off yeah was that fun
that was fun I mean that was a pretty
fancy into shoe obviously because I was
welcome to call and he was just like
amazing
so we had a really fun day and I had to
be really like upset and like scared
because she's being like kidnapped and
potentially tortured or whatever you
know so she's trying to like get a grip
but not doing a very good job a bit and
obviously there's this fight secrets
between Paul and Tony Jaa and he was
getting really worried about me like
Louise like running out of breath cuz
I'm he could hear me being like like
under this sack and it was like a really
fun really fun things she yeah so I that
was a fun bit and especially because
they reveal this hacker girl that you
might have some so stereotypical views
of what she might be and she's just not
that and that's kind of cool what's it
like now that you have your official
stunt woman card you're pretty great oh
I did some stunts yeah I I really
enjoyed it I mean it's something I've
never done before and I loved trying
everything yeah but I didn't get to do
all of them so obviously someone starts
a bit more dangerous and it's probably a
wise decision to have someone
professional do those and but I yeah I
definitely enjoyed doing that that stuff
because it it was really challenging
physically and I just had a whole new
appreciation for what like what the
stunt team do I mean I think they're the
coolest people on set anyway personally
but I had to actually do it I I felt one
of like like an action star there are
days you couldn't work as well as your
face I know absolutely there was days
yeah well there's one day where I had to
jump off the back of the bus but
obviously I'm not landing onto a car I
was landing into a big spongy thing
which was basically all my childhood
games come
to life and I'm doing it for work that's
kind of amazing I think there's a video
that James posted on his Instagram and
I'm like so happy and I think he yelled
at me like Nathalie can you stop having
so much fun as Miss I'm terrified I'm
like yeah but you put a giant sponge and
like it's so hard talking about an other
Derby and how much you enjoyed that
yeah I'm Debbie was beautiful and
nothing like I have ever seen before I
really enjoyed it they have so hot and
so I was quite happy that I got go into
the sea and stuff because it was so so
warm in the daytime but I really enjoyed
it like the people were so friendly and
we would welcome so warmly as well and
yeah I got to explore a little bit and
it's a pretty lucky place to visit you
as excited as the rest of the world for
people to get a chance to see the film
now yes I'm so excited I mean we have
it's been such an experience you know
we've been through so much and to then
be able to showcase what we've done is a
really proud moment and I just you know
I was liking the new girl and to be
included in that it's so special to me
I'm like I'm so excited that I
participation is just too much is it a
little overwhelming to realize the
appetite that people around the world
have for this bill yeah I mean the the
way the fans have embraced me is so
sweet I'm so amazing and so unexpected
before I've even they've even seen me
action they're already like yeah we're
so excited congratulations it's great
and I hope that I do them proud really
it's a big responsibility coming into a
series of films that people love so much
as these
you